hey guys it's justine and today we're
checking out the new sony bravia x900h
tv
it's 75 inches 4k hdr and we're setting
it up in my living room
right now and here it is
thank you so much to sony for sponsoring
this video and letting us showcase this
tv for you guys here today
oh my god i cannot wait until i have
time to do nothing but play video games
let me cover some of the key features
first the most important things to
highlight on this tv is the clarity the
contrast the color
motion and the sound now with the new
sony x1 4k hdr processor sony is one of
the only tv brands that can actually
incorporate their picture processing to
allow for an incredibly accurate
reproduction of what the original
creator had in mind for their content to
look like
there's even a netflix calibrated mode
so you can watch netflix originals and
reproduce the same picture quality
that comes directly from the studio so
here's netflix calibration off
and now let's turn it back on
[Music]
the display features a full array led
with extended dynamic range now what
this means is that the contrast and the
shadow detail is preserved while also
giving you really impressive highlights
now i know that i've been talking a lot
recently about shooting dolby vision hdr
content and even how to edit that
properly so you'll be able to display it
on a tv like this one that does support
it and this is actually some content
that i shot
in dolby vision hdr edit it on my phone
and now
it's airplaying to the tv what is that
is that a person or is that
so smooth so smooth
dolby vision hdr
i love it color is always something that
i'm always paying a lot of attention to
so this display uses the triluminos
display that is powered by the x1
processor to reproduce more colors
than any conventional tv it analyzes and
processes all of the data
in every single image to make the colors
even more natural
x motion clarity is a really cool
feature that will allow you to view
very fast action scenes without blurring
it optimizes
every single image and it boosts the
brightness as needed so it'll be super
smooth now the sound on this tv
is one of my favorite things because
there are the sound positioning speakers
at the back of the tv so it actually
feels like the sound is coming directly
out of the display
oh my gosh the control holy moly
everything is awesome
[Music]
now a lot of tvs usually have speakers
at the bottom so it doesn't produce the
same type of sound effect and now for
gaming has a 7.2 millisecond low input
lag
for really fast response time it also
has a bravia game mode that will
automatically detect a gaming console
and will switch the tv to low latency
game mode
wait for it oh look we don't have to
wait for it setup is complete
oh wow oh wow
so with that 4k hdr and full array led
you're going to get incredible picture
quality and the acoustic multi-audio
will give you that immersive surround
sound to match your game
oh my god this controller is amazing
wow it's so
freaking cool look at us playing around
with the places this is awesome
i love this so much
[Music]
much like most tvs nowadays they need to
be smart
this one has integration with google
amazon alexa and even works with apple's
airplay
and home kit alexa turn off living room
tv
i'm so excited for next-gen gaming and
all the content that has been coming out
recently to fully take advantage of 4k
hdr this tv is gonna be so much fun and
i just cannot believe
that the next gen consoles are here so
it really is like the future
is here now
so tell me